Pretty freaking powerful?
Yes, I agree.
Hey guys its Max from Max Tech, Its been almost
two years since Apple refreshed the iMac lineup.
We love our 2017 5K, but as the time went
on and Intel released new processor after
processor we started feeling like this was
the next trashcan Mac pro.
Thankfully, Apple didn’t disappoint and
we now have a 9th gen 8 core i9 available
that is rated up to 5Ghz.
Yes, this thing should beat he $5000 iMac
Pro is basically every task.
And Yes, we do have one ordered.
We’ll be doing direct comparisons and other
tests like benchmarks and gaming with the
new Vega 48 graphics so make sure to subscribe
and enable those notifications.
Now I do have a few serious concerns, but
before I talk about them and dig deeper on
the i9 model, I want to touch on the 21.
It used to be a good device for normal use
but with the addition of 6 core CPU’s and
new graphics, this will be the first time
I’ll be recommending the smaller iMac for
video editing.
For $1499 you get a sharp, bright, and color
accurate 4K display with the same graphics
that's in the $2800 Macbook Pro and a CPU
that’s practically as fast.
This does, of course, come with a Fusion drive
and 8GB of RAM, so I would suggest upgrading
to the base SSD for $100 more and if you can
16GB of RAM.
Have a bit more cash then spring for Vega
20 graphics and you’ll have a powerful iMac
rivaling my high-end MacBook that costs $1000
more.
Photo editing instead of video?
Skip the graphics upgrade go for 32GB of RAM
instead for a photoshop and lightroom powerhouse.
As always we’ll leave links in the description
for the models we recommend along with ram
which I’ll mention in just a bit.
Now onto the 5K.
Unfortunately, we didn't get a redesign with
slimmer bezels like we wanted but a benefit
of that is still having access to the RAM
slots which will save you some serious cash.
The base graphics have an X attached to them
meaning they are slightly faster than the
previous versions.
We have 6 cores across the board but the best
bang for the buck is the top $2299 tier since
its the only one getting a 9th gen CPU and
comes standard with 580X graphics.
Like always I’d spend the $100 to jump to
the SSD.
Apple charges a whopping $600 for an additional
24GB of RAM but we’re going to save some
cash and buy our own 32GB kit for only $180.
It easy only takes a few mins to install and
doesn’t void your warranty, In fact, Apple
even has a how-to guide on their website.
We end up saving $420 and as a bonus, we have
40GB of RAM instead of 32, which is enough
for most high-end users.
I’ll leave a link to the RAM I bought down
below.
So is this impressive?
I’d say definitely!
For $300 less than yesterday, we have an iMac
with faster RAM, Graphics, and Processor.
Apple has been charging more where they can,
so it's nice to see a cheaper Mac fast enough
for most 4K video editors.
So what about that iMac Pro Killer?
Like I mentioned Apple has been raising the
average sales price on its products and if
you opt for the newly offered i9 and Vega
graphics you’ll spend $550 more than the
previous top-spec 5K iMac.
But do I care, no not really!
Most people who buy this configuration can
afford it, and the price increase isn't for
an average performance bump but one that should
perform better than an iMac Pro.
[Show: professionals, business owners, People
who have a lot of money]
How?
Well, our 2017 iMac already performed better
in some tasks, but where it really struggled
is heavy tasks like RAW video editing because
it was limited to 4 cores.
We now have an 8 core option but with faster
clock speeds meaning that not only will it
have extra grunt when you're maxing out your
CPU but also for most tasks where you typically
don’t pin your processor to 100%.
The 9th gen architecture is also more efficient
so it also faster per clock than the Xeon.
Onto the graphics, we have a Vega 48 option
but honestly, I’m not sure how much faster
it is compared to the 580X or Vega 56 in the
iMac pro, but we will find out soon in our
full performance comparison videos.
I am fairly optimistic though since its a
much newer chip than the Vega 56 and because
the Vega 20 in my MacBook made a big difference
in performance and also improved temps.
This brings me to my first serious concern,
overheating.
Previous 4 core iMacs already throttled so
hopefully, we don’t have the same issue
as with the i9 MacBooks.
This alone may be a good reason to go for
the cooler running vega graphics.
Next is no 10GBe.
This isn’t a dealbreaker but since they
offer it in the iMac Pro and the new Mac Mini
I was hoping it would be available for fast
access to servers without adapters.
Finally, Apple didn’t include the t2 chip.
This is odd since it has a lot of benefits
and is included in all of their new devices.
I can only guess that they wanted to keep
this refresh as simple as possible since we
have the same exact IO.
Overall we’re happy with the updates as
we really weren’t expecting an 8 core in
the regular iMac or Vega graphics.
If you don’t need the very best you can
now get great performance for less money than
before, and even good 4K editing with the
21” iMac.
As a reminder, we do have links to everything
in the description, and go ahead and click
here if you want to see how this thing performs
compared to the 2017 iMac and the iMac Pro.
This has been Max with Mac tech and I’ll
see you in the next video.